hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
man I'm John Humphrey it's Saturday
afternoon and we're gonna watch a video
from mr. crup chest today it's called
Joker's this is a combination request
because a patron upped his pledge for
the top reward tier video request
whatever video requested was put up on
YouTube that comes from Matthew Cronin
asking us to check this out per his
request and then a little bit before
filming mr. Treves himself said hey if
anyone is requesting that you cover this
don't do it I hate the real rejects and
I never want you guys to touch my
content ever again and I said screw you
crap cheese we're gonna cover it anyway
we love your videos you may not like us
but we're gonna do it out of loving
spite that's come at me villain the
Bryan ad-libs mad libs are fun with me
[Music]
to bring laughter and joy to the world
Gotham has lost its way registers
changing dear this is awesome multiverse
yes
when I was a little boy this is amazing
[Music]
just getting crazier up there is gonna
spoil it allows them to be I'll show you
ship sit down
[Music]
yeah
see all your boys or maybe they have
changed
[Music]
yeah this cuts so well together cutscene
look like oh nice
[Music]
- that was that was awesome I just I'm
so happy right now you know as much as I
love this cut that he put together I'm
not entirely sure what he was exactly
going for was it like watching an
evolution of this Arthur Fleck character
sort of morphing into these journeys
what was that like Bob Dylan movie that
had like Christian Bale I'm not there
I'm not really there
you were elderly ya know which was
Joaquin Phoenix also in I'm still here
I'm still here yeah yeah whereas like
multiple actors were playing Bob Dylan
or like a variation of that it's one of
those titles about being here and I kind
of had that a little bit of that vibe to
it where you're watching like multiple
different actors or is it a thing where
it's multiple jokers is exuded one is it
the Joker of Joaquin Phoenix is giving
rise to the cult of Joker's and
everything you know there's so many
different ways to interpret just cut and
that's actually why I love it there's
more than one way to take this it seems
like it's had a one movie that was there
that was a crazy part about the way it
was edited like when it transitioned to
the Heath Ledger famous shot when he's
holding the mask waiting to be picked up
for the bank robbery yeah yeah the
trailer for Joker already has so many
other people and clown masks that yeah
sec you're like oh even if you recognize
it you may be like oh it's a tribute or
something yeah and so my initial
reaction was something along the lines
of this Joker movement is happening and
yeah I couldn't really tell which one
was sparking it off cuz we start with
Joaquin Phoenix but I almost felt like
Heath Ledger's Joker was the one really
rallying everybody and then you got
Jared Leto popping up out of that you've
got Joaquin Phoenix being inspired out
for that and weirdly because of all the
debate that's been going on about this
Joker movie before it's even come out it
almost feels like a weird alternate
reality where it's like the worst case
scenario of just like people being
inspired to go out and beat you it's
like yeah it works on so many levels and
yeah because everything is borrowing
from even though they're all different
tones the same lexicon they fit together
somehow
cross multiple decades like the vortices
Romero in there and as a Batman Joker
retrospective like it's super fun you
know that's just a tribute video if it
works incredibly well as pitching this
as one movie or you're crossing over all
these jokers it works really well this
is a great combo of a tribute video and
a fan made trailer yeah yeah because it
was so flawless it was seamless
yeah it's a medley of all these things
and yet they look like they're all
coming from the same thing lasing story
the same world
even they Jared Leto Joker's better yeah
the world of this because then it's like
oh their own this one community and then
the way that Joker behaves becomes less
annoying when he's not the only Joker
but yeah man and they even incorporated
Cameron Monaghan and stuff you know yeah
just for the credit portion which I
thought was great yeah yeah you know
yeah the thing that he took to was he
took the matically that kind of
especially the kind of monologuing that
we've seen from the arthur Fleck
character and the trailers but then you
know Heath Ledger's dialogue Jer letõs
dialogue primarily working off of those
basically finding these topics of
discussion of the point of views for
society themselves that are similar to
one another between the different
Joker's so that's a big part of what
made this trailer flow so well too was
even though you got very different
interpretations from all these guys
there's things within the scripting of
them that are similar enough because it
comes you know it's the Joker so yeah I
get that too when that happens well one
thing I do want to point out that isn't
in any way Joker footage related that
one moment that was just sounds after
the whole let's put a smile on that face
when I was a little boy boy boy was
pretty icky yeah this is over the black
screen in the dark night like there's an
abrupt cut at some point then shift in
tone and here yeah you just get to feel
also the nastiness of it like this
almost feels like a crime horror movie
yes this feels like a scary psychopathic
horror movie and with that being said
John I'm petitioning the Joker yeah
let's do it let's get it out of the
theaters the reason why there's violence
in the world is because the movies
because of this movie like these movies
are made because they're reflecting
things that have happened in real life
real life occurs because it starts in a
movie first and then we take it into
real life yeah that's what life is on
imitates art yes what's the phrases and
that's what that means you know I'm
telling you I how else would I know how
to behave unless you didn't watch movies
like the amount of casinos that have
been robbed by good-looking dudes coming
together to plan a heist
since the oceans French and this was
already launched now that is like a
choice has ruined image so much robbery
there's like our our financial
infrastructure is crumbling mm-hmm the
rise to secret hitman in the world since
the John wick franchise and and revenge
dog death to Ravana Glenny revenge
delegates so all time I would say that
yeah it's probably wise because this
comic book character has never existed
before
until Joaquin Phoenix anywho violence is
a real issue it's not unfair to bring it
into the county I think we should all
just wait and see you know I've made my
stance I have to made my stance yeah I'm
telling you like I'm never gonna see it
and I've made my stance when I saw 300 I
had the feeling of being inspired to go
work out sure enough I got a six pack
right away yeah that's how influential
we did and he also never wore shirts and
you adopted the Cape and diaper look
like it was
it was good any emotion a movie gives me
it lingers with me for the rest of my
life it doesn't leave shortly after it
starts smoking though now I got Ryan
Gosling interviews see and Johnny Depp
see it's the say there's a one-to-one
comparison
you don't really difference the singers
are real people I wanted to be them
built thematically in tune with the rise
of the joke yeah that's the thing is
like no matter what way you look at this
it works which is magical which is which
is also like in essence with the
character like this is a beautiful
little piece of Internet videography
right here cuz you can look at this
little trailer presentation so many ways
and get so many things out of it and
it's chaotic and strange and lurid and
awesome I just want to say Mr Krabs's he
followed me on Instagram so I followed
him back and I was looking through his
profile it's a really good looking dude
dude does he have like a lot like maybe
he's you know hides behind the editing
because he's hyper and attractive you
know stereotype editor for some reason
why I think of editors now I only think
of aldo jones you know who he looks like
a sexy 70s pop idol mr. Travis thanks
for putting together these videos man
this is another wonderful compilation
really can't wait till you had a million
followers even more than that because
you really deserve it dude anyways
you're kind of actual trailers for the
movie studio no and then we'll never see
these hey guys did you love this trailer
make sure to follow mr. Crouch's on
youtube you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell matthew Cronin thank you so much
for requesting this dude MC I did not
reply to your latest patron message here
you said hey guys I have another video
cross for you I don't know how you can
tell which to your patron is on but I
did pay the $50 yesterday for tier
membership and then switch back here's
the link I hope you guys liked it as
much as I do well I'm gonna give you a
verbal response no I faked my reaction I
lied the whole time because I knew Mr
treacherous would be watching this and
because you upped your pledge for a day
it just mean you know
faking my way I don't believe in
sincerity or honesty I like it 70% as
much as you
so Matthew just now that we're willing
Ally yep a pledge yeah whatever
simple thanks dog simple simple it does
we're a youtubers man we aka nothing we
say is genuine or real we have no
original bones in our bodies bones were
borrowed we are market assembled people
brand but thank you for being a part of
our face